Spirits near I call to you is anyone
with me today that doesn't make sense if
you move it - no then somebody has to be
there
hey that is just rude
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that bends over backwards to
deliver you scarily good theories and
when I say backwards I mean really bends
over backwards now Halloween fast
approaching we're about to experience
one of fall's spookiest trends and no I
don't need people dressing up as clowns
trying to lure children into the woods
so while we're on the subject this trend
is freaking me out sorry all you
trick-or-treaters but any of you who
show up in my house this Halloween
dressed as clowns might get yourself
reflux kicked in the chest consider this
your first and last warning anyway the
trend I was referring to was the
Halloween horror cash grab as every year
movie studios rush in to make cheap
scary movie sequels that'll get them a
quick buck and often in their collective
race to the bottom they're green
lighting projects that no one liked in
the first place
case in point the topic for today Ouija
a movie series rocking a solid 7% fresh
rating on Rotten Tomatoes I think it's
safe to say that the movie-going
audience wasn't clamoring for a sequel
on this one I can't blame them it's a
movie based on a board game and we saw
how well that worked out with battleship
a few years ago except here I hesitate
to even give it the credit of calling it
a game since it requires someone to move
that little plastic piece as though it's
possessed by a ghost and then lie about
it to the rest of the group which means
if you have a bunch of honest friends
like good old matpat here and no one
moves the darn thing you just have to
wait there and nothing happens here's a
better name for it sit there and look
like an idiot there's your truth in
advertising slap that one on to the box
huh sorry the rage pad is strong with
this one I'm just upset that I spent $20
on a piece of cardboard and a crappy
plastic triangle so why am I talking
about these movies when I could be out
there pumpkin picking or sampling some
exotic butters well as I watched the
trailers for this year's new installment
Ouija origin of evil something clicked
in my little brainy head this lame
modern horror franchise may actually be
connected to one of the greatest classic
horror franchises of all time The
Exorcist
in fact Regan the main character from
The Exorcist you know the one the vomit
spewing conduit for Satanic demons yeah
her she may be the one to blame for all
of the events of the ouija series we JA
Ouija I pronounced it we G as in creepy
Luigi I just double checked the
Cambridge English dictionary and it is
in fact Ouija in the US and in the UK
boom knowledge dropped ok maybe not in
the UK only in the US but you know it's
one of those things gif gif let's all
just get along and pronounce the gift
gift gift gift about we pronounce it
piece of [ __ ] board how about that you
heard me right I'm saying we G 1 & 2 may
just be the unofficial sequels to the
Exorcist how cool would that be well get
ready because we're gonna have ourselves
a devilishly good time today and be
warned because of the subject material
there are some graphic images ahead but
before we begin here's what you need to
know about both movies in less than 60
seconds start the clock now The Exorcist
starts in Washington DC where a tween
girl is living with her mother who
happens to be a famous actress the girl
Regan starts behaving strangely and Boll
saying peeing in front of company and
using very creative profanity care money
after a battery of medical tests
Regan's mom suggests that she is
possessed by the devil and seeks an
exorcism two priests are assigned to the
task after Regan redecorated the walls a
bit
the priests are separated the old one
has a heart attack and dies the young
one says they even come at me bro a
demon does indeed possessing the young
priest who then jumps out the window to
his death supposedly ridding the world
of the demon Regan is back to normal and
life goes on or does it it does at least
until the sequel weady starts out with
two young girls playing with a Ouija
board and talking about the do's and
don'ts of playing years later one of
them commits suicide so the other tries
to contact her using the exact same
board exact dun-dun-dun that actually
contact the spirit of another dead girl
named Doris who starts to terrorize the
room
friends and forced them to kill
themselves they eventually burned doors
his old mummified body and the Ouija
board and they lived happily ever after
with their PTSD or do they they do
probably until the sequel who y'all
caught up good no a bunch of you are
still probably saying that I'm crazy for
thinking that there's some kind of
connection between these two movies so
let's just start off with the one that
sparks my interest in this theory to
begin with the Ouija board
now obviously the Ouija board is
important in the movie named after it it
serves as a conduit through which
spirits enter the real world but now
let's look at the Exorcist sure
everybody remembers the big moments like
the head spin and lines like the power
of Christ compels you but I bet most of
you have forgotten how Regan herself got
possessed in the first place early in
the movie Regan tells her mother that
she's found a Ouija board in the closets
that she plays with it with her
invisible friend captain howdy okay time
out if someone introduces themselves to
you as captain howdy you're at best a
child molester and at worst a demon so
just walk away this has been a film
theory public service announcement now
before she found this Ouija board Regan
was fine but after she starts commuting
with captain howdy everything goes to
hell
he'll get it jokes are great though all
you astute theorists might be thinking
that correlation isn't causation that we
can't just say because weird stuff
started happening after we get started
playing with a Ouija board that the
Ouija board is to blame but let's turn
back to Ouija the movie which sets forth
three rules for safe spirit contact one
never played a graveyard to always say
goodbye so dumb that's the reason you
have a 7% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
Ouija and three never play alone it's
rule number three that's important here
in the first Ouija movie Debbie uses the
board by herself and it's what causes
Doris to start haunting her and it's the
same thing with Regan and captain howdy
she plays alone and she gets possessed
and mind you these aren't some general
rules from the board game they're made
up in the movie universe so there's
really no reason why the boards would be
so similarly in both movies unless this
happened to be a shared universe now
there's another problem here that some
of you are probably thinking in ouija
the teenagers aren't possessed they
summon the spirit of doris the angry
ghost of an evil girl that's nothing
like regan and the exorcist who actually
gets possessed by the devil
so how on earth could i say that these
boards function in the same way
well let's clear some things up first
regan isn't actually possessed by the
devil
to come and misconception and you can't
be faulted for making it when regan says
things like and i gotta put in the
exorcist to the heretic it's actually
revealed that regan was possessed by
Pazuzu an ancient babylonian we need a
demon if that seems completely random
it's actually not rumor in the first
movie that we see an archaeological dig
site in Iraq where father Merrin the
soon-to-be puke receptacle discovers a
figurine of a demon well that demon is
Pazuzu and if you look carefully there's
actually a good shot of Regan reaching
out to Pazuzu during the exorcism scene
at the end of the movie look at that
smart filmmaking guys no obviously I'm
not gonna argue that doris the little
girl from Luigi is an ancient
middle-eastern demon but I am gonna
point out that the new movie Ouija
origin of evil is a prequel about
Doris's origin story we can see in the
trailers that she didn't start off as
just some angry ghost
it appears that she uses a Ouija board
alone back in the late 1960s and gets
herself possessed by you guessed it a
demon spirit that comes out of the board
its own both Exorcist and the Ouija
prequel the board's function the same
way if you play alone you get yourself
possessed by a demon but without those
rosary beads loyal theorists because not
only did the boards act the same way but
the demons do too it's time to do some
demon alysus similarity number one
they're targets
Pazuzu and the Ouija demon not only come
into the world the same way but they
also use similar people as conduits both
Doris and Regan are preteen girls
without a father figure in fact in the
trailer for Ouija or
evil Dorris looks like she's trying to
contact what we assume is her dead
father through the board before she gets
herself throat punched by the leather
daddy [ __ ] demon Regan's father
meanwhile isn't dead but he does live
abroad in Italy and doesn't bother to
talk to his daughter even on her own
birthday
in both cases we've got young women
without a strong male presence in their
lives which makes it much easier for
them to be seduced and corrupted by a
male spiritual presence similarity
number two the eyes perhaps the thing
that most shocked audiences about The
Exorcist was the battery of grotesque
physical transformations Regan undergoes
throughout the movie you probably
remember her cracked skin and janky
teeth but on a number of occasions
Regan's eyes roll into the back of her
head and look all white luigi gives us
way fewer visual clues to tell us that
people are possessed well we do see the
group size turn that same milky white
when they're attacked by Doris but
that's just what your eyes do when
you're possessed by a demon objectives
of you who are suddenly experts on
demonic possession well here's the thing
I'd be willing to overlook this if light
eyes were a universally accepted movie
trope like how we have to walk slowly
away from something that you blow up but
it's not to the Exorcism of Emily Rose
Dexter's sisters eyes just dilate and
turn black when they're possessed and
sister Mary Eunice's eyes turn red in
season two of American Horror Story the
white eyes shared by Regan the kids and
Ouija and Doris in the origin story
isn't necessarily the smoking gun but it
is another prominent connection of these
sorts of possessions and we're still not
done just look at similarity number
three the demons powers probably the
best way to draw parallels between the
demons we see in the Exorcist in Ouija
is by comparing how they act and what
they're able to do and the overlap here
is actually surprising both demons have
the unusual ability to enable their
possess II to speak in tongues when
Pazuzu possesses Regan she's suddenly
able to speak several different
languages from Latin to French to
Italian fair enough
but then in the trailer for Ouija origin
of evil it's revealed that after doris
starts acting strangely she writes a
number of letters in Polish
huh interesting shared connection there
seems like both of our demons happen to
be linguistics majors and then there's
the subject of levitation some of the
earliest high jinks that even causes in
The Exorcist include making Regan's bed
levitate on the ground which by the end
of the movie is graduated to making
Regan herself levitate into the air
similarly George's victims in Ouija
levitate cleanly off the ground and even
Doris herself seems to be able to defy
gravity as evidenced by this clip that
we get of the new movie in which Doris
crawls her way up the side of the
staircase with her eyes in that glossy
white possessed look a scene mind you
that is very reminiscent of the Exorcist
nightmare-inducing body contorting
spider walk down the stairs
speaking of demons compelling their
conduits to move down the stairs and
creepy ways how about that classic
Exorcist flexibility well in the opening
of the Ouija origin of evil trailer we
see doors being bent backwards in a
position that would allow her to do
something like the spider walk in fact
both Regan's demon and Doris's demons
seem to be able to defy human anatomy
and contorting the body and ways that
should be breaking the little girl's
bones and joints see it the owl head
spinning The Exorcist or Doris's jaw
drop so there are a lot of similarities
here yes some are shared in large part
with possessions in general but a lot of
this like the languages and the back
beds are specific to this movie
franchise but still at the beginning of
all this I claim that Regan may have
started the events of Ouija and for all
the similar possession rules and demonic
powers in order to really connect Doris
and Regan we need to simply connect them
via time and place and believe it or not
we can
that too although the events of the
Exorcist are never given a specific date
we know it occurs sometime after 1954
since Regan's mother Chris is set to
star in a movie about the Vietnam War
protests in 1954 is the year that that
war started but we also know that the
Exorcist takes place before 1971 since
that's the year the Exorcist book which
prompted the movie was written based on
the early release promotional materials
we know that the events of Ouija origin
of evil are set in the 1960s the late
1960s so the timing of these two movies
lines up but what about the location
well The Exorcist famously takes place
in the Georgetown area of Washington DC
where as Ouija origin of evil has taken
place in Los Angeles seems like we're
kind of out of luck right but at the end
of The Exorcist we see Regan and her
mother packing up to move out of
Washington DC here to get away from the
horrors they just went through and where
are they moving to I bet you can guess
it's Los Angeles
Regan's mother is an actress after all
that puts Regan and all her stuff
including one possessed Ouija board back
in LA the same city origin of evil will
soon happen in fact the trailer for the
new Ouija shows that Doris goes to a
Catholic school in LA and if you were
Regan's mom with a daughter who just was
possessed by a spawn of Satan wouldn't
you put Regan in a Catholic school the
second you got back to LA yes in other
words all the details line up for the
same Ouija board that possessed Regan in
Georgetown to be present in Los Angeles
and ready to possess Doris in Los
Angeles just a few years later let me
put it this way when it comes to the
Ouija movies Regan and the Exorcist
might just be the true origin of evil
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts leather daddy [ __ ] demon
leather daddy [ __ ] deal